you come from a real lineage of drinking
dude you're a northern european kid and
northern european kids like
like to move the vegetables they like to
move the vegetables explain to them
moving the vegetables is the term we
have on the show on the history is
moving the vegetables about my mom used
to keep her bruise
and then even though i haven't lived
there in 10 years she keeps the beers
you know the coors lights
and the bud lights that she would drink
or sometimes the sponge if my aniline
would come up
she would keep them under the vegetables
in the drawer in the refrigerator
because i don't like vegetables and i
would never
every time open the fridge i would never
look to grab vegetables or the salads
so that's what she would keep the beer
so she would hide them when we're having
drinks we say we'll move in the
vegetables she would
linger vegetables and grab a spot
there's no there's no hiding
no my family you knew down the open yeah
you embraced the dragon
fire yeah you become it see we i grew up
catholic so it was a lot about
repression
oh no my mom was like my parents were
were partiers
yeah but you could tell you could tell
my parents met they met in san francisco
in the 70s
yeah drinking just [ __ ] ripping it my
dad's swedish
descendant to uh san francisco to the
bay area
a lot of swedes there's like a swedish
contingency there
right so his grandfather moved to sweden
from uh south of stockholm
hence the name soda cedar shader
what did we say that it meant it meant
south it means south and swedish means
puddle in germany that's right germany
means puddle in german
the germans do not like the soldiers but
i always thought of the scandinavians as
like because they're all germanic
they all descend from like the same
germanic tribes yeah but like
something happened where like the
scandinavians became like good and like
well
russians just want to take [ __ ] over i
think what it is is they didn't become
good as much as they became isolated and
drunk
right people don't realize man swedes
[ __ ] drink oh yeah
i've seen it firsthand my father my dad
died of cirrhosis
his dad died of cirrhosis and my
great-grandfather i all i believe also
died of kidney failure so it's like and
and when you go to stockholm you know
when you go to sweden their government
monitors the liquor stores yes like in a
way not in the united states
not like taxation or anything right like
they're like is that a close-ups at all
yeah
we had enough you can only buy liquor on
a certain during certain times in
certain government stores yeah yeah your
family lineage is like was like a
drunk relay race to have kids dudes like
we've had kids before we die
it's like a [ __ ] a wet bar napkin
[ __ ] a coaster
that's what happened how many brews
would your dad slam a day you think at
the tide of his drinking
beers are for [ __ ] my dad drank an
entire liter
of uh bacardi rum daily
daily one liter of bacardi yeah rum and
cokes
mostly rum splash coke at the end so
wake up wake up in the morning my dad
would wake up have a coffee
a cigarette we'd read the san francisco
chronicle front to back
come back in the house [ __ ] around you
know take a dump
maybe take a shower there was times
where he worked at a liquor store so
you could never really monitor his
liquor intake but read the san francisco
chronicle front to back so he was a
smart articulate man and that's where
you think that's why you're so smart oh
maybe my mom
my mom uh my mom's an intelligent lady
but
my mom came from a family of alcoholics
three out of my four grandparents are
alcoholics both my parents are
alcoholics
you know what's interesting but danny is
not danny's a sober [ __ ] kid
so danny are you not drinking alcohol i
don't drink alcohol i smoke weed yeah
yeah but alcohol is the thing that it's
a personal problem
yeah alcohol was the factor in my family
that was taken so you remove that one
you know it's like it's i think i bought
a couple more years eliminating giannis
is
many honest is one of the uh reasons i
quit drinking he's one of the three
people that really like in the very
beginning were like yeah you gotta
[ __ ] watch this
yeah you're down at cb's drinking and i
got giannis to do a shot and i [ __ ]
banged back a double of jamison like it
was like i was walking through
water yeah he he drank like a like a man
yeah i used to be like a man
he used to drink stella's with uh uh
jameson back honest is the kind of guy
he tells you the truth we call him yanni
tough hanks because he's a tough hang
i gotta deal with giannis you know every
day i love you i love on instagram and
you're like i'm in for a long day and
it's
honest going into another thing yeah you
didn't have to deal with this
yeah so so i get but but the the
positive part of that is he can make you
see your problems as he made me see mine
he uh i can't i can never thank giannis
enough
because he introduced me to my therapist
and
uh told me i need to quit drinking which
put it on my brain yeah because he said
something
it's a very honest way of saying it we
were sitting at this bar
upstairs at seabees and we had beers and
he was like i could walk away from this
beer and go home
yeah and i said in the second you'd walk
away i'd drink that beer yeah and he's
like yeah you got a problem dude yeah i
remember you used to do that
yeah i remember at bar four there would
still be like little half beers
and he would finish other people's beers
and i was like wow yeah yeah
yeah but when you see somebody have a
beer
and then a side of like oh i would say a
shot with a
the side the back would be the beer yeah
the the jameson would be
yeah nate was always nate pargotsy was
always like i mean just stop doing shots
and i was like that's what i do
i i drink with the shots and then the
beers are just there to come for me yeah
i need that yeah when you drink it's it
was
it's clear to see it's a different thing
well that's why but i mean to overcome
years of family history and not do
it is [ __ ] not easy it's just a true
feast
we really hope you enjoyed that episode
whatever it was about this is just a
stock thing that we're taping on to
every episode
so go make sure you rate review us
subscribe uh turn on your notifications
get jiggy with it and go to
patreon.comridgeboys where things get
really wild